[Musica]
d
buongiorno a tutti sono nina zilli e di
solito scrivo quello che canto
chiaramente però come già ha fatto
presente lui prima di me mi piace molto
confrontarmi con realtà diverse dalla
mia no che siano alcune volte molto
simili come presentare una trasmissione
televisiva fare il giudice di italia's
got talent
piuttosto che disegnare illustrare un
libro o andare in libano per scoprire
cosa succede veramente per assaporare no
quando vogliamo capire cosa succede
veramente quando siamo lontani anche se
in un mondo di connessione purtroppo
credo che vivendo in un medioevo
digitale
non abbiamo ancora i mezzi almeno tutti
non hanno ancora i mezzi per riuscire a
muoversi bene nei meandri di questa
realtà del web e quindi a parte il
fiatone che ho fatto tre passi in alta
montagna sono già scoppiate incredibile
ho portato con me un telefono perché
oggi sono qui in un contesto molto
diverso non devo cantare ma vi devo
raccontare una storia e raccontare la
precisione una idea ho portato il
telefono perché chiaramente va beh nella
speranza anche di potermi spezzare la
scaletta ma poi come alle superiori con
i bigliettini non la farò ma perché è
simbolo della società odierna
con questo aggeggio infernale oggi
possiamo fare tutto se non ce l'abbiamo
siamo persi possiamo fare quelle famose
videochiamate connetterci da un lato
all'altro del mondo che kubrick sognava
in 2001 odissea nello spazio possiamo
comprare possiamo decidere dove andare
possiamo capire come raggiungere un
luogo
praticamente è la nostra la scatola nera
della nostra vita
e questo anche per i poco tecnologici
come me e io tento di essere
tecnologicamente diciamo utile per
esempio tentò di essere socialmente
utile mentre vedo che al momento questi
social la socialità la connessione del
mondo tecnologico
forse più puntato in qualche modo non si
capisce perché piuttosto che verso
l'empatia e la connessa
non è reale verso l'odio qualcosa di
molto negativo quasi diventano uno sfogo
ecco credo che questo sia colpa
chiaramente del medioevo digitale in cui
stiamo vivendo per cui arriverà il
risorgimento di questo ne sono certa ma
sicuramente qui dentro anche per quelli
meno tecnologici ma molto ecologici come
me c'è una soluzione un'idea una
proposta molto interessante per l'europa
oggi infatti sono qui come maria chiara
fraschetta più che come nina zilli
perché mi sento cittadina di questa
terra di questo pianeta un pianeta che
appunto come hanno già detto prima non
sono una scienziata ma non ci vuole
molto per capire che in fondo il
coronavirus e tutto quello che è
successo sia strettamente legata al
problema del surriscaldamento globale e
il coronavirus in un secondo una cosa
che neanche si vede che non è tangibile
ci ha fatto stoppare completamente le
nostre vite le nostre abitudini sono
cambiate non non potevamo più fare
quello che eravamo abituati a fare ci
sembrava così assurdo
e invece no no perché perché madre
natura è chiaramente il boss è lei che
detta le regole di questo mondo non
siamo noi e forse il capitalismo che è
una cosa anche molto buona no per
l'economia per il libero mercato per lo
sviluppo delle idee forse ha un po
spinto troppo su certe leve dovrebbe
diventare un po più etico e che dovrebbe
avere forse una morale dovrebbe fermarsi
a un certo punto non ci dovrebbe essere
questo divario anche di ricchezza non
questo secolo
dovrebbe esserci pace e prosperità
perché di solito la storia no che
insegna così come diceva vico nel 500
invece siamo in questa difficile
situazione
il clima di emergenze addirittura al
plurale e io ho scelto sul riscaldamento
globale perché credo che sia
un'emergenza alla quale proprio non
possiamo rimandarla ecco c'è
assolutamente necessità di invertire
la rotta si può fare intanto noi per
primi cittadini europei possiamo ad
esempio firmare la proposta di stop
global warning punto eu è un'idea
meravigliosa è molto facile semplice e
diretta più tasse sulla co2 meno tasse
sul lavoro e come è possibile questo è
molto semplice chi più inquina più paga
e diciamo che questi soldi poi tutto il
ricavato insomma di queste di questa
nuova tassazione andrà da una parte
alleggerire quei ceti che non ce la
fanno e quindi andrà ad aiutare tutte
quelle persone che non riescono ad
arrivare a fine mese e dall'altra parte
invece andrà a favorire delle politiche
dell'economia volte all'uso di fonti
rinnovabili al risparmio energetico
ovviamente questa bellissima idea non è
farina del mio sacco ma è stata pensata
coordinata e studiata da 27 premi nobel
11 mila scienziati e 5.000 economisti in
italia il portavoce marco cappato io
insieme a tantissimi anche i miei
colleghi del mondo dello spettacolo e
non solo ci siamo fatti testimonial
perché credo che sia giusto in questo
momento l'europa ha finalmente diciamo
il surriscaldamento globale non è più
considerato una cosa per ragazzini ma è
una cosa di cui si è accorta anche le
unione europea è una cosa che è stata
messa nelle priorità del 2021 il carbon
pricing carbo prese che è molto facile
insomma i leader mondiali dovrebbero
semplicemente fissare un prezzo minimo
per le emissioni di co2 e da quello
tutti inizierebbero a pagare le tasse
certo forse qualcosa di più dovremo
pagare anche noi ma a seconda del nostro
stile di vita se noi riusciamo a
cambiare associare le nostre abitudini
dobbiamo anche noi non solo i leader
mondiali ovviamente hanno la
responsabilità più grossa sono loro che
possono dare la sferzata questo grande
cambiamento
noi nel nostro piccolo possiamo fare
molto meno ma sicuramente carbon pricing
risparmio energetico uso di fonti
rinnovabili e fare questo passo proprio
per cambiare la situazione spetta ai
leader
ma noi abbiamo anche una grossa
responsabilità perché comunque dobbiamo
diventare io per esempio sono figlia
degli anni 80
siamo cresciuti con il concetto di
spreco uguale a praticità
non possiamo negarlo lo spreco invece
spreco adesso l'abbiamo capito perché a
furia di sprecare ci sono discariche
nascoste sotto parchi naturali in italia
abbiamo le isole di plastica in giro per
il mondo e anche nel mediterraneo nel
tirreno dove tra l'altro ci sono insomma
i cetacei che la plastica nella
gradiscono tanto quindi come esseri
umani noi dobbiamo essere i primi a
strisciare cambiare mentalità dobbiamo
diventare dei consumatori intelligenti
critici non ci dobbiamo fare abbindolare
non dobbiamo essere la società dei
consumi che consuma in modo spasmodico
dobbiamo crescere anche noi come
individui come società e come
consumatori è importantissimo fare
sentire la nostra voce partirà ma
dappertutto
io sono qua sto facendo sentire un
microfono durante i miei concerti perché
possa amplificarla però veramente
dobbiamo farlo tutti noi potete fare io
sono qui per dare questa spinta petu
l'area indignarvi davanti alle
ingiustizie convincete il vostro vicino
di casa
andate e scendete in piazza insieme a e
greta scrivete una canzone come ho fatto
io ma insomma l'importante è fare
qualcosa perché guardate basta un
piccolo passo avanti per lasciarci
dietro tutte le cattive abitudini
certo è che dobbiamo sempre guardarci
indietro perché indietro c'è la storia
che è la memoria e quindi per costruire
un futuro migliore non ci dobbiamo mai
dimenticare del passato
mi raccomando
[Applauso]
[Musica]